on prime crime he was giving my
eight-year-old too much attention
i had a bad feeling about him a monster
lurking in the shadows
a crime so heinous it brought jurors and
witnesses to tears
i'm sorry i have to take a break can i
just have like five minutes
can a convicted killer get another shot
at freedom
he is going to be brutal with any victim
if he were out i think he'd have more
hey everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile and memorable
true crime cases what you're about to
hear
is every parent's worst nightmare okay
ma'am
what's your daughter's name her name's
cherish
and her last name periwinkle with the p
june 21st 2013 jacksonville florida
rain periwinkle and her three young
daughters are shopping in a dollar
general store
the periwinkle family didn't have a lot
of money and rain couldn't afford to buy
her eight-year-old cherish a new dress
that's when someone took notice i looked
to my right and he was standing in the
doorway looking right at us
he said you look like you have your
hands full i have a couple of little
ones
fifty-six-year-old donald smith is
watching rain and the kids
when he then offers to help them he
claims he has a 150
gift card to walmart and his wife can
drive it to them
he saw this window of opportunity where
he would be able
to use a weakness financial insecurity
and he realized that he would be able to
entice
them with money to be able to get time
with these girls alone
smith then even offers to drive them in
his van to the walmart
an offer that rain accepts i was dark
there were blinds on the windows
there was no seat in the middle and the
passenger seat
was pushed all the way down
[Music]
at the walmart video surveillance shows
rain and the girls shopping
while smith just looks on and as each
minute passes
there's still no sign of smith's wife
it's so ominous to see things like that
because you almost want to reach out
and try to change it in that moment it's
heart-wrenching because
this is the point before which things
will never be able to go back in time
later on smith suggests buying the
family food from the mcdonald's in the
store
again rain accepts it's at this point
cherish follows smith to get the food
there's nothing distressing about that
video he is not
holding her hand he is not pulling her
arm he is not dragging her by the hair
he is not pushing her she is not
resisting him
if all you had was that video in this
case
hey that's her granddad and how awesome
is that he took her to walmart
but as this video shows they don't stay
in the store
instead smith leads the eight-year-old
outside to his van
where they get in and drive away
number one robinson hi that was almost
i'm in turn i think my daughter's been
taken
what do you mean taken by stranger i
can't find her okay and she was laughing
with this man
yes he went he said he was going to
mcdonald's and he
hasn't been there because the store is
closed right now i had a bad feeling
about him
okay how long have you been looking for
when was the last time you saw your
daughter how long ago
about half an hour ago all protectors of
children
need to know that these predators are
out there and there is
a level of blame when you entrust
someone you do not know
to be around your child who is
defenseless
i had a bad feeling i thought well
i feel like pinching myself because this
is too good to be true
he was giving my eight-year-old too much
attention
he wanted her to buy these really tall
shoes that were women's shoes and i told
him no
you know listen i know people don't like
her
it was a bad decision but think about it
she is vulnerable she has no money
she is desperate and she's manipulated
she's a victim like cherishes a victim
i don't want him to kill her
i should have told him no
despite reigns please on the 911
they don't initially classify this as an
abduction rather
a missing person's case authorities
wouldn't even inform the media
or issue an amber alert for at least six
hours i don't think law enforcement
actually believed her this is my opinion
so as a result of law enforcement saying
hey
uh we're a little skeptical we may not
believe the mother's story in this case
i think they could have found him with
cherish
sooner and we do not know if that means
she still would have been alive
the next morning police finally tracked
down smith
as he's driving his van on the highway
they also receive
a new call hi we were calling about a
suspicious van over here on a white van
it was parked behind some bushes it's
not
there anymore but we don't know if you
don't do anything because we heard a
girl just got a doctor from walmart
authorities then find the worst
cherishes dead body
lying in the marsh of a creek this
depraved indifference to
life and the clear ability to just
injure someone who is so defenseless and
small just shows
a level of sociopathy that we actually
come to know
is in fact the way mr smith is
i had a strange feeling about him when i
first met him he took her to the
he took her to the to the dressing room
twice
and i was hoping that she would be okay
eight-year-old cherish periwinkle is
found dead the morning after being
abducted at a walmart
in jacksonville florida the autopsy
would reveal she had been repeatedly
sexually assaulted and then strangled to
death
donald smith is arrested and later
charged with first degree murder
rape and kidnapping it shows me that
number one it was someone who was
absolutely enraged and number two was
someone who had done this before what's
even more disturbing
smith is a sex offender with a long
criminal career
arrest ranging from burglary to battery
to crimes against
kids including when he was caught
masturbating in front of two miners
yet on the day of cherish's kidnapping
he was out free
every instance where he could have been
incarcerated or hospitalized for long
periods of time
he seemed to skate by and get out and
the individual reasons
may have made sense for each individual
case
but at some point there should have been
a totality of the circumstances to say
he's been given this opportunity in this
opportunity and he is a perpetrator
that's going to reoffend
he shouldn't be out on the street i
almost feel like he had nine lives
and that's not a good thing it took the
murder of an innocent
eight-year-old for those lives to catch
up with him
he became sexually aware at five years
of age
he started to engage in voyeurism
and public masturbation by 10 years of
age
he had a traumatic brain injury with
loss of consciousness and scalp
laceration
at nine years of age this is his
historical
behavioral issues that i would call
concerning smith's trial began on
february 12
2018 over four years after cherish's
death
the prosecution's first witness reign
periwinkle
what did he say to you when you walked
out the front door of the dollar general
if you really want that dress i'll get
it for you
he got snappy with me because i wouldn't
get in the van
i think part of what troubles people
about her testimony
is her honesty
why did you ever let her around him
i felt foolish after that i thought i
was just being paranoid
she's heartbroken she's devastated but
also she's honest
ma'am when your daughter followed after
this defendant
towards mcdonald's was that the last
time you ever saw your daughter alive
yes thank you
while the prosecution would present a
strong case the defense
did a curious thing in their opening
statement they seemed eager to fight
and even cast blame on reign do not make
any fixed opinion at this moment
but when it came time for smith's team
to cross-examine reign
smith says no in fact the defense
chose not to call any witnesses nor
offer a closing argument
oddly if you blame reign it doesn't
really help
your case because you're essentially
saying that she was
so negligent that she allowed such a
crazy killer like your client
to then have contact with the children
so it doesn't really advance the theory
very much
it was really tone tone-deaf insensitive
and they backed off
we would learn a lot more about smith
including things
he never intended to be revealed
[Music]
at donald smith's trial for the
kidnapping rape and murder of
eight-year-old cherish periwinkle
emotions ran high including with jurors
crying
in one of the most dramatic moments when
dr
valerie rau the medical examiner took
the stand even
she broke down yes so what we do is
it's uh i'm sorry i have to take a break
can i just have like five minutes
do you want a five minute break it's
just testament to the brutal nature of
this crime
it's an eight-year-old anybody's
sympathetic empathetic compassionate
about a child
but here this medical examiner is having
to testify as to all the gruesome
details
and how horrific and probably the worst
the medical examiner's ever seen in
jacksonville florida
before prosecutors finished up their
case against smith
they delivered one more blow they played
secretly taped conversations
between him and another inmate in jail
[Applause]
he's a perpetrator this is what this man
does and
he's never going to stop in my opinion
[Applause]
[Applause]
it was unbelievable that in facing these
types of charges
he would continue to speak so freely
like that in jail
and here's the thing it really shows
that he was
intending to do this that this was
something he planned
to do he is attracted
to young girls and to committing
violence upon them
the jury sealed smith's fate it took
them only
15 minutes of deliberations to come back
with a finding of guilty
across the board then it became a
question of whether smith should spend
the rest of his life in prison
or be put to death we heard from various
experts discussing everything from
smith's brain abnormalities to his
history of himself being sexually abused
all as possible mitigating factors his
imaging studies show profound atrophy
when i was looking at mr smith's
abnormal behavior
there were we can say two general
categories of neurologic
illness one was a neurodegenerative
disease
such as cte or frontotemporal dementia
and then the other was a various form of
epilepsy
he has what would be called a
orbito frontal syndrome hypersexuality
disinhibition inability to control
inappropriate impulses poor judgment
recidivism saying he can't control
any impulses that's too strong i'm
unable to say that
it's it's a balanced thing just because
somebody has had
mental health problems or even
neurological problems
it doesn't mean that they do not
appreciate
the severity or the consequences of
their actions
but what we didn't predict was the
testimony of a woman who says
smith tried to kidnap her when she was
13.
he told me to get the fuck in the pen
did the defendant chase after you in
that van he did
i was horrified that kind of terror for
anyone much less a 13 year old girl
i can imagine the trauma i was slipping
and i was so afraid i'm gonna fall out
and he was gonna
find me
he said i know you're in there you
little bitch
i'm gonna find you it's so similar and
it was so long ago
and that's what's such a problem and it
really speaks to gaps in the criminal
justice system
it speaks to what could we have done
it should never have taken this long
once again the jury sided with the
government
and recommended death with judge mallory
cooper
ultimately imposing the sentence it
broke out crying
but uh no it's not justice you know
um the legal is just the worst way it
works but uh he's been living for five
years after the death of my daughter
and he's gonna be living until the the
death penalty is either done or whatever
the case may be and that's not justice
uh
she didn't get that option to live those
many years you would think this would be
the end of donald smith's story
it isn't all i know is that
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions welcome to prime
crime tonight another day of drama
between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law on crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this is law and
crime
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father guilty
or
not guilty guilty think again judge
caprio rules with common sense
i was having contractions i was rushing
to the hospital inspector quinn what
does justice demand
jail and compassion i'm going to take
the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had
clearly judge he's been in a court
before get caught
in providence
[Applause]
after donald smith was convicted of the
brutal rape and murder of eight-year-old
cherish periwinkle
and sentenced to death the world learned
about another side of the killer
recorded jailhouse conversations between
smith and his mom
came out this is
way bigger than anything it's way bigger
than anthony
[Music]
and they know
what's disturbing is how involved and
excited he was about the attention that
he was getting
and so we can see this collateral almost
benefit that he is getting from this
smith actually denies being a child
molester
i don't view children
that is bizarre obviously that is laced
with
complete dishonesty but it might just
have been something that he was telling
his mom
or that he wants he doesn't want to be
perceived that way in jail because child
molesters in jail of course
are exposed um to a lot more violence by
fellow inmates and they also are not
given a lot of priority by the jailers
in one of the most shocking admissions
he suggests that as a registered sex
offender
he had no choice but to kill cherish
when she followed him
blaming the victim i think is how he
rationalizes in his sick brain
how it's okay and why it's okay oh it
wasn't my fault
it was her fault she made me do it this
little eight-year-old girl and i'm a sex
offender and it's her fault not mine
i think that's a sick way of
rationalizing it
then smith appears to strategize a
mental health defense
even asking his mom for a copy of a
manual on psychiatric disorders
that's how manipulative he is that he's
manipulating his mother
to get these things so that he can do
the best he can to get out of jail
at the time of this taping donald
smith's defense team has appealed this
case to the florida supreme court
arguing he's entitled to a new trial
see i never predict whether or not
someone's going to get a new trial
because you never know
one of the grounds for instance is
change of venue and they say there
should have been a change of venue
because it is true this was all over the
news all of florida was talking about it
they argue that means potentially jurors
could have been affected and biased
the prosecution's response to that is
listen you can ask for a change of venue
but
that's already been discussed that's
already been decided and none of the
legal grounds for a change of venue were
met
one of the grounds for a new trial that
the defendant is trying to make is
the emotional testimony by the medical
examiner
and i don't think that that in and of
itself would be enough for a new trial
because we have so many other basis for
the jury to have decided for guilt it
wasn't
simply what the medical examiner was
saying
and also medical examiners are human
beings they're allowed
to emote as long as it's done
appropriately within the context
of their testimony and here the medical
examiner even asked for a break
to be able to compose herself so i do
not think that that ground would be
sufficient for him to get a new trial
the reality is he is going to be brutal
with any victim if he were out i think
he'd have more
at the end of the day though this case
has always been
about the loss of an innocent young girl
she was um well
it's hard to explain that and you'd
never see her unhappy
she was never miserable she never had
any signs of anything she was just
smiling
just this big a smile on her face every
time you've seen her and i know you've
talked to people jacksonville they'll
take the same thing
to have an eight-year-old just be taken
out like this it's just
it's just unreal um i just hope they
remember
her smiling face and the fact that she
had a good life ahead of her and would
have probably
been very successful at something but
we've never known now
donald smith ended up in the one place
that he'd been trying to avoid
for years rotting away behind bars
waiting
to die this is really one of the hardest
stories to cover
it's one that just stays with you but
when i look back on it
i don't focus so much on him instead i
like to think about cherish
because even though she's not here this
is a girl that had an impact on
so many and she always will that's all
we have for you on prime crime
leave us your comments on twitter and
instagram with the hashtag primecrime
as always thank you for joining us and
until next time
be safe
[Music]
you